Go to the ground.
Fred Pleitgen has been on the front lines
in Ukraine.
And Fred,
what are you seeing there tonight?
Are there and what we're seeing is that
the fighting is drastically picking up.
We saw some vicious battles
going on to the north of where
I am right now,
massive exchanges of artillery
but also fierce ground
fighting as well in force
as the Ukrainians and the Russians
are fighting for turf.
Here's what we're learning
Ukraine's entire
eastern front is now heating up.
This is Russian
infantry in a massive firefight
in the forest
near the town of criminal Donetsk
close by.
We're creeping through the same forest
with a Ukrainian frontline
drone unit called Dnipro, one
that scouts out
Russian positions and
direct Ukrainian fire
Drone operator
Ruslan says
working in the forests
is extremely dangerous.
All time work intense.
A lot of artillery from
different directions, from
east and from north.
But the team is often able
to spot attempted Russian advances here.
Russian infantry
are moving through the thick woodland
and this tank leaves cover and opens
fire towards Ukrainian positions.
That's mostly
the Ukrainians
liberated towns
and villages in this area last autumn.
But the scars of battle are visible
everywhere.
This village
like many of the ones in this area,
was heavily damaged
when the Ukrainians moved in here
in fall. For a while, it was quiet.
But now all that is changing.
The fighting is coming back.
And it's heavier than ever before.
The few people remaining, those too poor
or too old to flee are the new.
I ask Valentino
if it's not too dangerous to stay here.
Yes, it is dangerous, he says.
But what can we do?
Of course it's dangerous.
But we endure. Sometimes we hide.
But now it's too cold at the base.
The Russians
have massively beefed up
their forces around Crimea.
They believe
they have to prevent the Ukrainians
breaking through here
to sustain their own
offensive against Bermuda
and are now also launching
fresh attacks near Vladimir
further south.
This video near Voulu
shows Russian armor
getting hit by Ukraine's artillery.
The soldiers run away.
A wounded comrade tries
to crawl to safety in all these places.
Drones are critical to detect
and to destroy the enemy.
Dnipro one has its own drone workshop
where NATO's issued
grenades are literally sawn
and have to be carried on drone launch.
Yuri can manufacture
drone munitions in 20 minutes
and they've proven
very effective in the conflict.
NARA's ordnance
drone operator
is one of the most dangerous
jobs, the boss says.
As soon as they locate a drone operator,
they use
all kinds of weaponry, artilleries
and the last tanks.
We have a high rate of casualties
among drone pilots, even a fixer here
in the forest
whose lands mission is now over.
But he sees a long battle ahead
in a contest of wits and brute force.
Mostly
last month, our arm exhausted
but lost to think.
Two weeks,
maybe we stop
and Russians making counterattack
and all the time.
Drones will shape the way
this war changes
I think important to point out,
Erin, that
what you heard there in that report,
those thuds, those artillery thuds,
those explosions,
we were on the ground
for several hours in that area.
And it did not stop
at any time that we were there
and we were witnessing all of that now.
The Ukrainians say they believe
what is actually going on there
is that a lot of the people
that Russia mobilized late last year
are now arriving at the front lines.
The Russians are beefing up
their presence there
and they're going on the counterattack.
And while this might not yet be the start
of that spring offensive,
they certainly believe it could
be a prelude to it Erin.